On January 23rd, 2014, a mystery emerges that
will take investigators from the deserts of
Mars. To the birth of one of the greatest
civilizations on earth.
There's an obvious.
Crater in the landscape here in Mexico, but
it's not so much the crater that catches my
attention. It's what's inside this crater.
This is intriguing because what we're seeing
is this white color.
And boy, it sure does look like ice.
It's so unusual because we're talking about
Mexico and this white patch stays here all
year round.
The mystery White Crater is one of a cluster
known as the seven luminaries, which, when
viewed from above, mirrored the Ursa major
constellation.
To NASA's Kasha Patel, this extraterrestrial
connection may be more than just coincidence.
This crater reminds me of something.
But it's not on Earth.
This crater looks pretty similar to the
Korolev crater on Mars.
The Korolev crater in the northern lowlands
of Mars contains enough water ice to fill
almost a billion Olympic swimming pools.
Most of the ice found elsewhere on Mars is
mixed with frozen carbon dioxide.
But it appears that the icy regions in the
Korolev crater are composed of more pure
water.
The crater is named after visionary rocket
scientist Sergei Korolev, who during the Cold
War, helped the Soviets to outsmart NASA by
landing the first spacecraft on the moon.
In a twist of fate, the space agency hopes
his legacy will be key to the future human
colonization of Mars.
Ice is such a precious commodity for humans.
It can also be used as rocket fuel.
If you can make hydrogen and oxygen on Mars.
Fill your rocket for a one way trip and then
you gas up on the other end and you fly back
to the earth.
What stops the ice from melting during Mars's
70 degree Fahrenheit daytime temperatures is
a process called cold trapping.
Cold air goes.
Into the crater and it forms sort of an
insulating layer.
So any of the water gets trapped there as
water ice.
Could we be seeing the same process in
action in this image?
But our planet's atmosphere is 100 times
thicker than on Mars, creating swirling winds
which prevent cold trapping from taking
place here in Mexico.
The Earth has a very dynamic atmosphere that
tends to even out the environment.
So this is something very different that
we're looking at.
According to those who live nearby.
The crater did once contain water, but it
was bleach like and killed everything it
touched. To geologists.
This suggests the mystery white substance is
the legacy of a catastrophically powerful
volcanic event.
This means the water inside this crater is
extremely alkaline.
That tells me that this is most likely
sodium bicarbonate.
It's very broad, but it's very shallow.
This crater has all the classic features of
a maar volcano.
Mar volcanoes are formed by phreatic
eruptions, which are known as the nuclear
bombs of the natural world.
The more volcano occurs when shallow magma
intrudes into an area that has a lot of
groundwater. It creates an amazing amount of
energy.
Vaporizes this water, and it creates a steam
explosion.
After the explosion, water fills into the
bottom of the crater.
Sometimes you can get volcanic gases still
seeping in, so you end up with this highly
alkaline volcanic soup.
Over time, the ground around the crater dries
out, concentrating the volcanic soup into a
chemical sludge.
As that water evaporates, it concentrates it
further until we get these large fields of
crystals that form, which is what we see in
the image.
Scientists have recently discovered the
crater's floor is covered with a
cyanobacteria called spirulina.
Spirulina itself is a very simple organism,
but over history it's been considered a
superfood.
What we found is that the Aztecs used it as
one of their primary food sources.
They'd harvest large quantities of it.
They considered it the food of the gods.
Around 100,000 years after it devastated this
part of Mexico.
This strange white crater may have helped
give rise to one of the greatest
civilizations in history.
This is almost like a museum of the Earth's
earliest prehistory.
It's a fascinating place.
July 18th, 2019.
High above Kansas.
Eyes in the sky.
Capture something out of place in a farming
community far below.
At first glance, it looks normal.
But if you look closer.
There's some structures here that a farmer
would not have on their homestead.
A double security fence surrounds a 105 foot
diameter flat concrete platform.
And a close analysis of the approach road
reveals This is no ordinary structure.
Paying attention to the shadows is really
important here.
Where the road comes in to the compound, the
shadows really give the impression that the
road doesn't stay flat, but actually dips
down.
Is this compound hiding secrets that are
somehow related to a more sinister purpose.
Military analyst Carlos Munoz finds some
historic images that seem to confirm that
this rural landscape conceals a terrifying
secret.
The remote location, the security perimeter.
What looks.
Like an underground bunker.
It is the launch site for a nuclear missile.
Declassified military records confirm this
location was one of a series of top secret
bunkers. Armed with Atlas E nuclear
missiles.
The Atlas missiles were the first
intercontinental.
Ballistic missiles armed with enough
destructive power to destroy a city the size
of Moscow or Saint Petersburg.
What puzzles analysts is that the Atlas E was
mothballed in 1964.
But the missile silo doesn't appear to be
abandoned.
If you look at the satellite images, you'll
see the road, you see the cars, you see a
digger. So, you know, there's activity
happening at the site right now.